عندما ينتهي
هذا المستشفى الضخم من أي وقت مضى ، فإنه يقع في ثاني
أسوأ نقطة ساخنة في المملكة المتحدة ، ميدلاندز وليس لديه
إجابات سهلة ،
لذلك بينما يستمر رجال لندن هنا
الأحياء والمحتضرين في القدوم ويخشون
أن الموجة الثانية قد تكون قريبة ، نتطلع إلى
الأرقام من أجل الراحة  ولكن في وحدة العناية المركزة هذه ، فإن
الاحتمالات تدور حتى مع الأطباء السريين
يقولون خلال الـ 24 ساعة التي كنا فيها هنا
، توفي مريضان وخرج اثنان من وحدة العناية المركزة
حيث ينتشر الفيروس في عالمنا العادي
في الخارج هنا ، حيث تكمن قوته
في الهدوء الذي يفرضه بدءًا من هنا  أنت
لا ترى فقط ضراوة هذا
المرض ولكن الصمت الذي
يقتل به وأيضًا عجز
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من طبيب واحد ارتدوا كاميرا الجسم
أثناء إجراء إنقاذ الحياة المتمثل في
قلب المريض في المقدمة
لتسهيل التنفس دون مائة
في المائة يفهمون لماذا يعمل بشكل
أساسي ما يفعله هو أنه
يغير توزيع الهواء داخل الصدر
ولكنه يغير أيضًا طريقة توزيع الدم
داخل الصدر إذا مات الناس
يحدث ذلك في كثير من الأحيان لأننا
توصلنا إلى استنتاج مفاده أنهم
لن يبقوا على قيد الحياة مهما فعلنا بدلاً
من أن يموتوا فجأة وهو الأمر الأصعب بالنسبة
للموظفين أن العزلة تعني أن المرضى يموتون
هنا بدون أسرهم القريبة من
الأطباء والممرضات هم آخر
الناس.  أرى على قيد الحياة لقد حملت
هاتفًا على أذن رجل نبيل
كان يحتضر حتى تتمكن زوجته من
التحدث معه أنه كان مخدرًا ، لكننا
دائمًا
ما يمكننا أن نسمعك إذا كانت الممرضات اللائي
يعتنين بالمريض يجلسن في
كل مكان  لقول وافتهم المنية أيضًا ،
لذا فهم دائمًا مع شخص ما عندما
اعترف زملائي بأنهم
خائفون ، أعترف أنني قلت إنني خائف أيضًا
الآن ، لقد استمر هذا الأمر ، وأعتقد أن أفضل ما
يمكننا فعله مع مكان تقاطع أصابعنا مع معدات الوقاية الشخصية
أننا لا نحصل عليه ،
نعم ، لذلك أنا خائف ، لا ، لا
أشعر بالخوف كما كنت عندما بدأت ، كانت هناك
سفن صعبة حقًا كانت موجودة ، لقد بكيت للتو
في الحمام الذي دخلت فيه - أمشي ، أبكي
في الليل ، هل يمكنني البكاء مرة أخرى لا  انها
مجرد جدا انها مجرد جدا  أنا خائف ،
أنا خائف فقط ، وأنت تعلم
أنني فقط في الأساس مثل ، انتظر هل
سألتقط هذا كما تعلم لأنك
تعلم أننا هنا نتعامل مع
مرضى مصابين بالعدوى على الرغم من  إن امتلاك
معدات الوقاية الشخصية القديمة وما زلت لا تعرفه ، أليس كذلك
حتى إذا ذهبت إلى الكتاب ،
فلا يزال هناك أشخاص مصابين ،
لذلك أنا خائف جدًا من أن
هذا لم ينته بعد وليس من الواضح ما إذا
هذه بداية النهاية أو فترة
هدوء قبل موجة أخرى نحتاج إلى
الاستمرار في الإغلاق الذي
يجب أن نوقف انتشاره ، وهكذا على
مدى الأسابيع الستة المقبلة ظل المرضى واقفين
يتفاقمون ويحسنون
جاكلين التي أخرت قدومها إلى
المستشفى بسبب  لقد كانت تخشى أن تلتقط
هناك الفيروس الذي أصبت به بالفعل
يتحسن ، فطلبوا سيارة الإسعاف
ثلاث مرات وظللت أرفض القدوم ،
وكنت خائفًا من القدوم ، يا
إلهي ،
إنه ضيق للغاية لديك شخص
يجلس على صدرك وأنت تحاول
أن تتنفس وأنت لا تصل إلى
أي مكان فهو جدا  المخيف أن هذا المستشفى قد مات أكثر من مائة وسبعين مريضًا بسبب تغطيته ، والآن أصبح لديه حوالي مائة وسبعين مصابًا به أو ربما يكون لديهم على الإطلاق ، مما يجعلهم مستعدين وحذرًا من موجة ثانية في جائحة مليء بالمجهول الذي يتركه مؤكد فقط من مقدار حاجتنا لبعضنا البعض نيك باتون والش سي إن إن كوفنتري في المملكة المتحدة